[Music]
your existence
may you be blessed
[Music]
we understand that viewers in some parts
of the region are receiving a
breakthrough in sound
we're sorry about this and we're doing
our best to rectify the fault
forty years ago a strange incident took
place on an english television station
november 26 1977 was the same as any
other day for the uk southern television
network
at first came the news bulletin however
the tv picture wobbled slightly
and the sound of the reporter faded
behind a mysterious distorted voice
[Music]
for many years
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
the engineers tried to get back control
of the station
you can see this battle on the screen
behind villan's message
the visuals on the tv continued as
normal finally
the network regained control and the
voice was gone
the thrill on message is a long one but
undeniably one of peaceful intent
calling for the removal of all weapons
of evil and promising that those who
learn to live in peace
will pass to higher realms of spiritual
evolution vrillon mentions the new age
and talks about the upcoming age of
aquarius
this perhaps shows a little too much
humanity and reveals some of the
ideology of those responsible
if you're familiar with hippie culture
or astrology this might sound familiar
in the late 60s a bunch of spiritual
systems popped up predicting the new age
of humanity
an age of enlightenment peace love and
understanding
this will happen when we enter the age
of aquarius
to some astrologers earth time is
measured along the zodiac
there are 12 astrological ages
corresponding to this 12 zodiac signs in
western astrology
each time a new astrological age comes
around a great new development in
society
culture and politics will take place
there are some complex and pretty
dubious maths here
so i won't get into it but each
astrological age is about
2160 years the thing is
no one can quite agree on when this
astrological movement will happen
according to vrillon 1977 was on the
cusp of the upcoming age of aquarius
hippie's new age was big in the late 60s
and died out pretty soon after
whoever was behind it even if it was
aliens they were ten years
late to the party
but why aliens what do they have to do
with the new age movement and hippies
who's frillon and what's the ashtar
galactic command
you may have heard of the roswell
incident in mid-1947
a united states air force's balloon
crashed at a ranch near roswell new
mexico
eyewitnesses claimed to have seen a
flying saucer a ufo
that the u.s government were hiding from
the public ufos and aliens became the
next big thing
some even believed to be abducted by
aliens some even claimed to communicate
with them
and george van tassel in 1952 he claimed
to receive messages via telepathic
communication from an extraterrestrial
an interdimensional being called ashtar
and how did you did you go into this
ship i walked with him to a spot
underneath it
and an anti-gravity beam took me up
through a hole in the bottom of it
you're telling me at two o'clock in the
morning in giant rock airport you walked
underneath this hovering ship
of cuomo you went up into the single
guam oh you went just about as slow as a
local elevator and when you got off the
anti-gravity elevator
what did it look like i was inside of a
ship
about 18 feet in diameter and
roughly 10 feet high to the dome ceiling
and there were three men on the ship
besides the one that had got off and
invited me aboard
you keep calling a man what do you mean
man well
little green man they were about five
foot six
they came about to my eyebrows and uh
they
could have walked in our clothes down
any of our streets and we wouldn't have
paid any attention to them
what color were these people they looked
uh
like they were white people with a good
healthy pan
did they give you any indication of how
old they were or what they ate or where
they came from at all
after we got off the ship the man who uh
invited me aboard who didn't look a day
over 28 years of
age told me that he was over 700 years
of age in our time
oh come off a job that's right
he gained some followers and i set up
the first ufo religion
the ministry of universal wisdom there
are so many ufo religions
and it's a crazy rabbit hole to go down
you might know scientology
or alienism or heaven's gate but van
tassel's ministry of universal wisdom
was the first alien cult
it was claimed on july 18 1952 that
ashtar entered the solar system as
commander-in-chief
of the ashtar galactic command to warn
humanity of the dangers of destinating
the hydrogen bomb
but why should these people come down
these
from outer space why don't they land in
the white house or on kremlin square in
moscow and say
hey listen to us we can tell you a few
things we're 700 years old
we can travel through space we're not
concerned with time differentials
well uh probably they're not concerned
with uh giving us too much of their
information because we'd only use it in
our battle to destroy each other here
did the did these four men
tell you that themselves no they didn't
tell me that but this is a reasonable
assumption on our part that where the
world's divided in two camps each
capable of eliminating
old civilization and if we were to go to
another planet and observe this
condition we would certainly be a little
cautious about who we talked to or what
we revealed
so going back to vrylon's message it all
seems very familiar
vrillon a representative of the ashtar
command is kindly warning us
to destroy our harmful weapons and we
can ascend to spiritual enlightenment
vrillon's message seems to be a fusion
of ufo spirituality and new age hippie
beliefs
this is by no means a new thing both
ideas are related to cosmology and space
with universal truths presumably
applicable to aliens
to my mind the whole thing probably
isn't aliens it's most likely a hoax
mostly because this alien voice spoke
with an english accent
and the fact that the aliens only
managed to hijack a local tv station in
rural south england
make it more likely the source was a
human possibly a broadcast student
or maybe an outdated spiritualist
pulling a hoax
unlike so many of the broadcast
interruptions which came after
mostly in the usa there's nothing
prankish or funny about the vrylon
interruption
there's no punchline or swearing or
obscenity or explicit protest
no one ever came forward and claimed
responsibility for this episode
whatever it was the southern
interruption goes unexplained
you